todo el mundo en baño un suburbio de
parís ha sido invitado a hacerse la
prueba de kobe 19 esto debido a que la
nueva variante que se está extendiendo
rápidamente por el reino unido ha
infectado a algunas personas también
allí la nueva variante podría ser
peligrosa habito mucha gente por aquí
durante las vacaciones y queremos ver si
están contagiadas o no
no estoy más preocupado que antes y
seguimos las medidas de distanciamiento
deberíamos estar bien
cómo llego hasta francia sigue siendo un
misterio fue detectada en una empleada
de una escuela local pero no había
viajado al reino unido- lo que significa
que la variante ya se había extendido en
los alrededores del otro lado del país
en marsella algunos han dado positivo en
la nueva variante detectada en un grupo
de familiares es una de las razones por
las que el toque de queda se adelantó a
las 6 pm estrategia no muy bien recibida
por las autoridades locales todos
coincidimos en que no era la solución
adecuada
quiero evidencia científica de que el
toque de queda a las 6 de la noche
reduce más los contagios que el de las 8
de la noche a medida que los casos
aumentan el gobierno está ampliando el
'toque de queda' de gran parte del país
de las 8 pm a las 6 mientras tanto se
espera que más de 100.000 personas estén
vacunadas para el fin de semana